really excited for jt he's had a lot of
firsts this year but today
i think this is what he's been waiting
for that chance to get on the bump and
start this game and this stuff has been
absolutely outstanding 12 games played
before today and the twins have scored
16 first inning runs they're in position
to get something up on the board here in
this first inning first and third two
down the line deep
and it hit a seat but not the foul pole
well they called it fair it's a home run
and sonos hit a three-run home run
if that ball hit the foul ball probably
would have knocked it down that was an
absolute laser the only question was
whether it was going to stay fair or
hook foul so
twins another early lead
and more of the same and good to see
from miguel cino staying inside that
ball not trying to do too much
blind shot just fair down the line and
it's three to nothing and maeda so far
he's been brilliant two starts
12 strikeouts only two walks
mayda to bell three and two the count
avila sets up down and away and the
payoff pitch is swinging a looper into
center field byron coming on and byron
makes a running catch right above his
left hip and that's out number three a
couple of pop flies then a
more
entertaining route for byron makes the
play for usual gregory polanco has just
one hit in 19 at bats he's got a couple
of rbis no homers
and polanco
decides to deposit one out to right
center
gregory polacco a three-run home run
that ends up in the allegheny
man that ball was touched
you know they've been attacking him with
that slider the entire series
just getting it right underneath that
barrel that time that get me over slider
looked like he was looking for it or he
was just able to adjust
109.7 off the bat bounces in the river
i mean that was loud it sounded like a
cannon just exploding off the bat look
at him just nice easy front side lands
soft and he just plays the barrel and
knows it right out the gate there's a
beauty
kepler down the line
and makes a nice catch up against the
netting
we saw max do that here a couple games
ago
on a foul ball in the corner a little
bit more of a challenge when you're
doing that in a visiting ballpark
byron now three four
twenty nine ball games and a pitch that
balls hit high in the air and deep long
run center fielder he'll turn around
look up and go on
byron buxton has hit his first home run
to straight away center field on a
fastball new score twins lead four to
three
a little home run trot there by byron
buxton
big old smile on his face that ball was
crushed sounded good on a fastball
there's a line drive right field kepler
up jumps up and makes the catch right on
the warning track
that was a line drive laser and kepp
all he can do is couple steps jump up
and a backhand play three up three down
through four i'll bring up eddie rosario
who has walked twice
today
he now has six walks on the season and
only five strikeouts
high fly
right field hit deep
back to the wall and it's gone a home
run
rosario with a solo home run
and it's five to three
two patient at bats he took walks his
first two times up that time got himself
a fastball right down the middle
and he didn't miss it hit it in the
seats and
good to see him getting rewarded for
number one being patient but also number
two
staying within the zone not over
swinging top of the order for
the pirates and that's fraser and he
bumps it down the third base tonight
barehanded by mayna comes up and retires
frazier nice play by maeda
and a smile on his face that was almost
about a foot
off the chalk line
no chance for adrianza
he bare-handed it and threw on
target i could have been a little bit
closer
to the foul line and he gets him but
they've tried to punt on maeda twice now
and he has fielded his position
and that bounder
with the team up two runs
and they'll collect the second out evans
gets a run ban it in
busted his bat but moran is aboard with
the tying run
until we get it started right there nice
two-strike hit
so he a tucker very speedy acts as the
tying run
reynolds now the winning run and that's
groud and a left for a base hit tucker
streaking to third
and he'll be held there on that ripping
ground double by reynolds and the bucks
have the winning run in scoring position
with nobody out in the knife
i like it the babylon bucko is coming
back
true fashion like they did a lot last
year and again this year they've been so
good after the seventh inning scoring
runs
real close right here to having a walk
off ryan reynolds doubles inside the
third base bag tying run 90 feet away
the go ahead run in scoring position
we're single
single away from
this one being over kevin newman pinch
hitting
that one up the middle and throw tucker
is in with the tying run here comes
reynolds he will score and mr walkoff
does it again
kevin newman is the hero and the bucks
walk off winners today
rocky called that one
said he loved that gatorade shower he's
gonna get another one today great at
that